Angela Merkel wanted to prove her
resolve even in the face of increasing
pressure from within her own party to
change her refugee policy she stood her
ground defiantly emphasizing the
government's success at significantly
reducing the numbers of refugees
entering the country with less evolved
Ebola citizens rightly expect us to help
those who need help but also that we
tell those who have no right to stay you
must leave our country otherwise we
cannot cope with our task Mackel also
defended that you use refugee deal with
Turkey saying it is the only way for
Europe to defend its maritime borders
but the opposition criticized the
government for being too accommodating
to Ankara pinprick you've made yourself
susceptible to blackmail with a refugee
deal and by submitting to mr. erawan
Chancellor Merkel you've lost your
political compass it cannot be that
German Foreign Policy puts human rights
on the negotiating table that is
unacceptable ladies and gentlemen
Michael also addressed her party's
shocking election defeat in her home
state of mecklenburg-vorpommern the
Chancellor said the best way to deal
with the populists anti-migrant afd
party was to stay the course Ben on
phone if we begin to take part in
sweeping aside or ignoring the facts
then responsible and constructive
answers will no longer be possible if we
begin to orient ourselves both in words
and actions toward those who are not
interested in solutions then we will
lose our orientation in the end phalion
on end via the oil until Mackel said
that the public's trust could be
restored if the government rigorously
Orient's itself toward freedom security
and solidarity